Learning by storing cases in memory has a very strong connection to cognition.
Cognitive agents like you and I are situated in a world.
Our interactions with the world have certain patterns of regularity.
The world offers us the same problems again and again. If we think about it,
the kinds of problems that you and I deal within a routine everyday basis
are the same problems that occurred yesterday and the day before.
Tying shoelaces is a good example of that. When we have to tie shoelaces,
none of us thinks a lot about how to do it. Memory supplies us with the answer.
We don't think as much as we think we do. If you recall we have drawn
a cognitive architecture earlier that had three components in it, reasoning,
memory, and learning. When we think of intelligence, we typically focus on
the reasoning component. We think intelligence has to do with reasoning,
with solving problems, with decision making. To some degree, that is true.
By learning by recording cases, shifts the balance between the component.
It says that, learning is very important and so is memory.
We recall things in memory and then memory supplies us with the answers so
that we don't actually have to reason as much as we think we need to.